[Music]
some of these popular TV series are too
scary to watch without a companion
others are just terribly horribly sad
bottom line you should definitely phone
a friend to keep you company before you
start binging any of these shows after
all misery loves company the x-files
still definitively has that x-factor
when it comes to being scary
particularly in the early seasons David
Duchovny and Gillian Anderson star is
FBI agent Fox Mulder and Dana Scully who
are tasked with investigating the
bureau's unexplainable cases their
investigations lead them to a long
series spanning arc involving alien
abductions and colonization but the real
frights come from the show's
monster-of-the-week episodes
take for example the early season 1
episodes squeeze in tombs which tell the
tale of a man who can stretch his body
to squeeze through small spaces he makes
a nest of his own bile the hibernates
and resurface every few decades to
murder his victims then there's home an
episode that has been called one of the
most frightening of the series and was
forbidden from being replayed on Fox
when the series turned to reruns the
less you know the better but trust us
when we say it's truly terrifying on a
whole buttload of levels
Netflix the haunting of Hill House is a
loose adaptation of the 1959 novel of
the same name by horror fiction master
Shirley Jackson it takes place in
multiple time periods and follows a set
of siblings the crane children whose
lives are forever affected by some
seriously frightening and traumatic
events at a mansion known as Hill House
TV Line recently voted the episode the
bent neck lady which explores the very
real horrors of sleep paralysis as the
best single episode of television in the
drama category for the entirety of 2018
that ought to give you an idea of how
powerful the show can be to top it all
off it sounds like Hill House might be
going the Anthology route creator Mike
Flanagan told Entertainment Weekly I
don't want to speculate too much about
season two what I will say though is
that as far as I've ever been concerned
with this the story of the crane family
is told it's done it's hard to imagine
something scarier than a television
series based on the works of whoremaster
Stephen King Hulu's Castlerock draws on
many of kings locations tales and
characters combined into one creepy
series starring Andre Holland is a
criminal attorney melanie lynskey as a
real estate agent who can read minds and
bill skarsgård as a Shawshank inmate who
claims to be from an alternate dimension
with references to King's works The
Green Mile misery the shining and many
many more Castle Rock seems to capture a
certain signature for that King is known
for its not always jump in your seat
scary but the show runners have lovingly
adapted the mood and feel of Kings work
particularly claim has been given to the
episode The Queen which focuses on a
character played by the fabulous [ __ ]
Spacek it might be a bit more sad than
scary but hey watching sad things alone
isn't a great idea either
would you leave me like many other
popular horror series castle rock is
adopting an anthology format
albeit one with storylines that might
carryover from season to season in July
2018 Kosho runner dustin Thomason told
The Hollywood Reporter each season is
going to be its own self-contained story
beginning middle and end but I think
that just as the books do we want to
surprise viewers with the ways in which
the stories intersect
aside from kitchen appliances coming to
life taking over the world and enslaving
humanity you probably haven't thought
much about how the technology you depend
on has the potential to create your very
own personal hell scape enter black
mirror a British import acquired by
Netflix which aims to torture us with
tech created by Charlie Booker black
mirror tells its tales and single
episode formats kind of like the
twilight zone or the Outer Limits much
like those shows some are more
disturbing or frightening than others
some are downright uplifting such as San
Junipero star in Google and Bottari and
Mackenzie Davis as a young couple who
find happiness in a virtual afterlife
some on the other hand are straight-up
laugh-out-loud hilarious in a disturbing
way of course take for example the bryce
dallas howard led nosedive which digs
it's claws into our dangerous obsession
with social media and the dystopia it
could inspire still the vast majority of
the episodes are downright terrifying
like the coincidentally named white bear
and white Christmas which both present a
criminal justice system in which
perpetrators are imprisoned and tortured
inside realities that aren't exactly
what they see
AMC's the terror has been described as a
horror thriller disguised as a period
drama the inaugural season was based on
Dan Simmons is 2007 best-selling novel
of the same name and stars Mad Men's
Jared Harris as captain Frances Crozier
whose 19th century Arctic exploration
turns deadly when the arctic breezes and
two giant seafaring ships are trapped in
ice a mysterious menace begins killing
off the sailors one by one but it's not
clear if the menace is super
human or if the sailors are simply going
mad what's more frightening than not
knowing if the horrible things happening
around you are real in June 2018 Variety
reported that the terror had been
renewed for a second season which will
reportedly be set on the west coast of
the US during World War two and focus on
a Japanese American community
Star Trek's George Takei is set to
appear as a series regular portraying a
former fishing captain and an elder
figure in his community Collider reports
a Takei who spent part of his childhood
in a Japanese internment camp will also
be acting as a consultant to ensure the
accuracy of historical events and
storytelling based on the novel of the
same name by Gillian Flynn HBO's sharp
object stars Amy Adams as crime reporter
Camille Parker after struggling for
years with alcoholism and self-harm
Camille returns to her hometown to
report on the murders of two young girls
Patricia Clarkson plays Camille's cold
and distant mother and you're here oh my
god you can move away and forget that I
can you know the people here anymore in
addition to telling a gripping story
sharp objects acts as a study in
depression
Camille's flashbacks are blurry
disjointed and untrustworthy her
self-harm is heartbreaking and her line
of work only contributes to her
inability to dig out of a hole that
keeps her trapped in her own troubled
mind
what makes sharp objects all the more
tragic is how very real it can be unlike
shows that deal with supernatural
elements Camille's story is one grounded
in reality and experienced by real
people every day her isolation and
fractured family life make for a
difficult watch for anyone with a
troubled past
Camille might be alone but make sure
you're not without a friendly hand to
squeeze when the tension gets a little
too high it might seem odd that Ryan
Murphy the creator of the happy musical
high school drama deeply could also be
responsible for FX's American Horror
Story one of the most brightening shows
on television American horror stories
anthology framework allows for a
different setting every season some are
scarier than others some even flirt with
a horror comedy genre it's one pate pate
vision but all of them have their
moments it all depends on what really
makes you jump whether it's witches
scary clowns haunted houses or even
politics there's probably an American
Horror Story season that is tailor-made
to set off your worst nightmares and the
repertory casting puts actors like Sarah
Paulson Evan Peters Kathy Bates taissa
farmiga and Jessica Lange among many
others in different roles every season
which allows them to stretch their
creepiest acting muscles if anything it
provides audiences with the comforts of
some familiar faces throughout all of
that unfamiliar darkness let's get one
thing straight
while this Netflix series in its early
90s sitcom counterparts
both take inspiration from the pages of
Archie comics Sabrina the Teenage Witch
this adaptation definitely embraces the
chilling part of its title starring
madman's Kiernan Shipka the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina focuses on the 16
year old title character who must
reconcile our status as half witch half
human
Brina we what we need to ask you which
you wish in addition to trying to decide
between pledging allegiance to the Dark
Lord Satan and hanging out with her very
human boyfriend Sabrina also battles
literal demons that threaten the way of
life she's always known what's really
scary for one person might be totally
fine for someone else but Sabrina
definitely has a creep factor that will
make you wish you weren't alone
particularly when it comes to the whole
Satan thing that's one creepy take on
everybody's favorite fallen angel check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you